my name is Joe McKai and these are my
Reflections from working for the last 10
years in veterinary
science this is actually a talk about
environment management but when I'm
talking about environment I want you to
think about culture that is the
unwritten rules that a group of people
agree upon when they work in close
proximity or exist in close proximity to
one another the central question for
this talk is how do we make the vet
school environment that I work in
compatible with the posit conon
environment not the same you guys at
posit conf are not going to be vets and
my vets are not going to be fully data
science practitioners but they should be
able to talk to one another a little bit
more than they currently
do I'm not going to spend a huge amount
of time telling you guys what the posit
conf environment is like you're there
I'm here in Edinburgh but I think we do
share some key ideas about good data
science practice it's importance and we
probably share some ideas about what it
looks
like let me tell you a little bit about
the Edinburgh vet environment we are a
very old vet school we are called The
Royal dick School of Veterinary studies
we have the word dick in our title and
we just own it we're that old we're that
respected we are the
dicks we also have with us the rosin
Institute you may know them from their
work with Dolly the sheep from their
work with uh Co over the last couple of
years and they have some of the best
bioinformaticians in the world I'm not
talking about teaching data science to
these guys they have forgotten more than
I would ever learn well we also have our
vets these are both our students who
have to be day one competent vets when
they graduate but also our clinicians
who are amazing in the field of One
World Health the field of animal health
but they are very time poor and at
Edinburgh we have both International
impact but we also believe it's it's
important that we make local impact as
well this might seem really complicated
and specific in terms of environments
but I suspect it's really really similar
to any of your workplace environments we
have subject specific experts who are
really really good at something that
they do who need to know enough data
science to talk to for example our
bioinformaticians who are really really
good at their data science part of their
role and not everybody has the same
amount of time available able to them to
do data science although it is creeping
into everybody's role more and
more I'm going to do two I'm going to do
three things in this talk I'm going to
change talk about how we've changed our
formal data Science teaching I'm going
to talk about how we've changed
workplace culture and I'm going to talk
about how we're trying to change some of
our operational practice at the end of
this talk I'm really hoping there's
going to be a long uncomfortable silence
and then somebody's going to have to
clear their throat and say we're really
sorry Jill we've actually solved this
already it's it's all here on this
lovely GitHub repository that's perfect
posit will have paid for Edinburgh to
get a Consulting session and I get a
lovely big tick in my Performance
Management review at the end of the year
so that's what we're aiming for guys I
suspect we're going to have a little bit
more of a discussion about some of the
barriers to institutional change that
occur particularly within the data
science
context we teach a huge number of
students we teach public engagement with
massive open online courses we're very
big on open educational resources our
undergraduates we have our Bachelor of
veterinary medicine and surgery which
takes on about 200 students a year is we
also have our Bachelors of Science in
agriculture and I just think it's
important to highlight that we also have
a Bachelors of Science in veterinary
science which is what's called an exit
degree so if somebody enrolls into the
veterinary degree get to the clinical
stage and they realize they don't want
to do it they can still exit recognizing
their learning while we don't offer that
as a degree to en roll on it is a degree
we offer and I think it's a really
important one actually and that also
includes the research project if they
want to graduate with the BC honors so
there could be our teaching in there for
example our post-graduate top programs
are many and varied we have a host of
online programs distance learning
programs which we've been doing for many
years and they all sort of serve a
professional development kind of purpose
often our students are those who are
already working in the sector and are
looking to upscale particularly their
research because we are a research
intensive
University we also have our postgraduate
research that's a little different from
the uh North American context our
postgrad research students are not
enrolled in any classes they sort of
learn by doing the practice of research
embedded within a research
group within our undergraduates over the
last 10 years we have seen a lot of
curriculum overload with our vets so we
don't have the opportunity to completely
teach them or re uh change how we teach
their data science we do however offer
optional R teaching within their
research projects if the student and
their host research group wants to go
down that path for agricultural bsc's
which we started in
2016 um we do do all of our stats and
data teaching in our from first year and
that was really important to us we
recruited a lot of staff for that very
purpose unfortunately our agb's are no
longer recruiting partly because of
covid and that's meant that we've lost
those staff members um who had that
expertise in our teaching hold on to
that this is going to become a common
narrative within our top programs as we
were expanding our post-graduate top
programs we realized that we really
needed to provide more research stats
support so we created a new role called
the stats Guru and they were pretty
influential in trying to encourage every
new program and every uh new resar SE
Arch course to do their teaching in r at
a distance I'm sure you're all familiar
with some of the challenges that that
can bring we did try to support the
campus with this with our r at rsvs
resource um say that three times fast
and part of our issue here is that our
initial stats Guru has since left us and
our new stats Guru is not quite such an
R effici ad so you may think we talk are
forever more but the big problems we're
running into is we need skilled people
to teach our and they keep leaving we
don't have the staff time for those who
remain on program to take up that R
teaching because they can themselves
learn R quickly enough and we also have
a recurring issue which our programs
feedback to us that student satisfaction
suffers when they teach R and I think
this is really important when we're
talking about those students who are
doing this for professional
development we realized that we kind of
wanted to look at how we were talking
about art in our culture and one of our
very skilled people Ian handle created
something called the data methods
Club if you've worked in any kind of
University environment any lab
environment you'll know how common it is
to get an email saying I need more of
this particular reagent to work uh my
experiment data method Club aims to make
it as easy to ask for help with an
analysis as it is to ask for an extra
reagent
we have a range of approaches we use a
book club where which is more for S of
slightly more comfortable our members
for example we use parties which are
protected analysis in our time yay um
and these were really effective this was
bicking out a room um inviting people to
come to the room to do their analysis
away from their emails away from uh
interruptions to their office and we
would always have some people who are
pretty comfortable and are in the room
just floating around ready to
troubleshoot if needed this was hugely
hugely successful we also run occasional
sessions and there's our aforementioned
email help if you take one thing away
from this talk take away the recurse
center social rules we explicitly
encourage all of our data methods club
members to follow them and it helps to
make a really constructive learning
environment so we supported our Forever
More on campus well not really the
global pandemic really uh impacted how
we ran our data methods club and staff
time meant that we do struggle to make
this run it was supposed to be
self-organizing but it just hasn't
really worked out that way it does
require somebody to organize it Ian
retired and is now building a house and
sailing on his boat and I tried to take
some of this over but I then went on
Matt leave so this is a recurring
challenge that we have this staff time
problem something that I wouldn't have
thought of 10 years ago but has become
more and more clear to me is that we
need better data science in our
operational
practice as a vet school we have a lot
of quality assurance we have to
guarantee that those vet students we
were talking about earlier are what we
call Day One competent bets so we need
to know how we're teaching them are we
teaching them effectively are they happy
with our teaching all of these sorts of
things I for my sins I'm the vet
School's new director of quality
assurance and enhancement and we're
really interested in what data we can
use to better inform our
teaching teaching data is often managed
by teaching organizations and it is
highly confidential it cannot be shared
in any capacity so this to me is a
really obvious place where we can use
workflows to better support how we share
practice in Scotland our quality
assurance is what's called enhancement
Le that means that we are all meant to
share best practice and to just really
reduce the workload of everybody else
this is starting to slide away from
veterinary science and starting to talk
more about the UK higher education
sector as a whole but something we are
really trying to do for example is using
shiny apps to show the data processing
that we have got um that other
institutions can use our shiny app to
analyze for example their student survey
data that they have got from the same
place that we've
got
so where are we in veterinary science
with data science well remind me in 10
years I don't know I don't know if I'm
going to be here in 10 years H
considering we keep losing skilled
people but my two key points that I have
here is that we do keep losing skilled
people and we do need more time to
support staff so that they can teach
data science
practice if we were to think about this
as a git repository these are the issues
that I would log I would say that we're
losing skilled people too often that
that package updates far too often well
this is not actually a bug this is a
feature of working in a university we
are supposed to nurture talent and let
that Talent go off and do wonderful
things one of the things that we need to
do better and I would encourage anyone
teaching data science to think really
carefully about this is to utilize
extensive documentation and make it as
easy as possible for somebody to take
your course and run with it
I think Glasgow does this really really
well with their site teacher resource go
and check that out um I want to steal it
and use it for ours and I think we're
doing it reasonably well with our
quality assurance
work the second issue and this is one
that comes up again and again when I'm
talking to staff about whether or not
they want to bring in more data Science
teaching is that anything to do with r
or coding is really complicated and
timec consuming and the students hate it
I think we need to make to use of the
many many tools available there's so
much wonderful stuff going on at this
conference and we need to use it I
personally am completely putting aside
the Tidy verse versus BAS R for teaching
argument I think we need to use it as
easy as possible for those people who
are time poor I want to highlight here
our Global Academy of Agriculture and
food security does a really good short
course on data science for farmers and
just take a look at how basic that is
and this is aimed at the public and it
is really really good um but this is the
kind of level of data science that we're
actually talking about when we are
bringing in these postgraduate students
so making it as easy and accessible as
possible is so
important my final issue that I'm going
to log is that I don't actually think
this is currently possible in neoliberal
higher
education maybe this is a little bit
controversial I can't see the room um
but I think this is actually a
replication of the capital ISM issue if
you're familiar with UK higher education
we are in a bit of crisis at the moment
we have been on strike since 2018 off
and on and we have a lot of issues with
staff leaving with staff being uh burnt
out and the traditional benefits of
working Academia in the UK are being
eroded and a lot of very very good
people are going somewhere else because
of
it I don't know that there's an easy fix
for this and I don't know that anybody
in this room necessarily has the power
to change this but it would be entirely
remiss of me um to talk about my
Reflections in the last 10 years without
saying that UK Academia is not currently
a very friendly place for this I am able
to be here I able to do this because I
have been incredibly Lucky in my career
to always have secure employment not
everybody in Academia has this and
without secure employment people are not
going to be able to have the time to
develop these skills to a level where
they can then teach them to
others I hope I'm preaching to the choir
there but I do think it's something that
I have to explicitly say if anyone's
ever going to look at this talk again
this needs time and it needs support
from a management
level okay so now it's time for edra's
free consult time remember I want that
long uncomfortable silence and then I
want somebody to tell me where you've
already solved all of these issues and
thank you very much for
listening thank you Joe I wish you could
see we are very we we're very happy with
this talk you did a great job thank you
so much um we did have a question on
slido here uh we had one that said just
who leads those you know party yay
sessions that you described are they
student Le or is this something else H
so no unfortunately our parties are
mainly led by me at the moment um um we
have really passionate PhD students who
are really good at this sort of thing
but they rotate in and out of this so
quickly and this parties are mainly
aimed mainly aimed at staff supporting
staff to um get better um and to do
their analysis there we do offer it to
our uh so our P postgraduate PhD
students they are always they're just
kind of treated as staff our mes
students are Masters residential
students they kind of tend to come in we
have had the odd master of science on a
taught program come in but not too many
because they tend to be more on campus
um based and so many of our MSC students
are uh distance learning so yeah it's
it's mainly me to be honest I've
actually just set up another further
three today um and it it's me and
anybody else who likes to hang around
and I think this is one of the big
things is this isn't kind of really part
of my rle this is just something I'm
interested in and again without giving
somebody like me the space to do
something like this you're just not
going to upskill a group of people um I
see there's another question on slido
which is uh any tips to persuade
academics who have been using paid
commercial software for a long time to
switch to
R um for me the really obvious argument
is
reproducibility and I really like our
markdown on quartal for those kind of
things I've been trying to get people
into doing sort of package development
to S of show how that can support a
workflow um we have a big divide in the
vet school between those who uh do
really intensive data science and those
who for whom data science is just a very
small part of their role and it's really
really difficult to get those for whom
data science is just a small part of
their role to move away from um where
they started way back
when I this is something I would love to
talk about in a huge amount of depth and
I will try to pull myself back I think a
lot of this is actually how we teach
science because we teach science as this
immutable thing and I think we need to
think more critically about the
underlying philosophies of Science and
show how important it is to adapt as we
go my biggest tip is to lead with
reproducibility and the time saving um
of that but to be honest with you a lot
of academics um are still at the stage
of like color coding an Excel
spreadsheet uh to demonstrate how uh you
know who coded what data or something
like that and that's a problem you know
that is a fundamental knowledge problem
that we just need to keep talking about
it over and over and over again with
these communications so not a great
answer I'm sorry thank you so much Jo we
really appreciate you calling
in